what stands out to you about 2021 uh the
fact that for the first time in my life
other than college i moved to a new city
that was a very big one and there's no
part of me that regrets it or misses new
york
so that was a very big deal for me what
do you uh
about this move about austin itself but
maybe the move itself
maybe just the act of moving what what
um
what's great about it to you the fact
that i had forgotten what it's like to
have a huge
social network which i had in new york
before people started falling away and
then it really escalated as a result of
de blasio and the coveted restrictions
so to have a big crew here
um is something that was very
validating the thing that's also
exciting about austin
is that boston isn't a particularly big
town it's not particular great town but
everyone here at least in the circles i
travel in is kind of a refugee from
their towns so there is this sense of
camaraderie there is the sense of we're
building something together
back in new york when you meet someone
it would be like who is this person why
am i talking to them like are they a
normie are they going to be weird and
here there's
very little of that i think there's much
more sense of trust with one another
when you meet new people so that's
something that's really exciting about
um like i've been introducing all my
friends to each other and everyone's
been hitting it off like gangbusters
it's really great so i really enjoy that
about
i'm austin i'm enjoying you know the
weather the space
uh you ready kerouac any of this stuff i
have on the road i read and i read a
biography of him
i don't know if it was on i think it was
on the road uh where he
he talks about that feeling when um
you're going to some place you're
leaving a place and you're going
somewhere else
and the place you're leaving disappears
behind you yeah and all the people and
all
like that you just think about that life
and it's forever gone and there's some
inkling of that
where um
you get to realize you're almost
mortality because okay that's a chapter
and there's not many more and it was a
beautiful chapter
but now on to the next chapter is there
a melancholy feeling there no it's the
opposite i feel like i've been given a
new least on life because i didn't
realize to what extent there was this
subtext of hopelessness in new york and
also people who in new york you don't
appreciate or you appreciate it
consciously but you can't escape it
emotionally how much the winters get to
you psychologically
it's tough it gets dark so early it gets
cold you can't walk around like that's
the thing that's fun about or what's fun
about new york is that you know when the
weather's warm you could walk for an
hour and just enjoy the sunshine and
there's a lot to see and do but in the
winter you don't have any of that it's
it's brutal and here it's just
so that is something there's no
melancholy at all
well that's because there's
can we say something beautiful about new
york not the way it is now but the way
it
i could go on for days about how great
new york was what did you learn about
human civilization just life that was
beautiful from new york
i learned that there's a lot
of
really
unique special people out there
who are doing their little part to move
the envelope and make the world a better
place and that when you have a
city
where they're all there together at the
same time then that really moves the
world and i'm thinking of paris in the
20s in harlem in the 20s and
new york in the 70s and
la in the late 60s in san francisco
especially in late 60s things like this
they really punch above detroit
certainly at its heyday they punch above
their weight and and just really kind of
philadelphia in 17 1700s things really
start happening and that ripples
throughout the world you think austin
has a chance to be a paris that's in
some way yes because again it wasn't
all of paris it was the left bank of
paris and gertrude stein and hemingway
and all them in a little area so you
know when you read these history books
these scenes it's like 50 people like in
a 10 block radius these aren't these
huge
like davos conventions
you